one of the all-time greats Rick Barry
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
Ricky
Richie always good to talk to you I'm
great what do you think of all these
metrics like tracking speed and you know
you know what isn't it might be engage
can somebody play I mean did they know
how to play do they have a great feel
for the game I think in life he
everybody know overanalyze a lot of
things in life and it's getting to the
point of almost absurdity I did
something a while back and had a book
that was out doing something and I think
it was Jordan Cohen who end up working
for the Miami Heat for a long time and
we did a total analysis of players it
probably was the most sophisticated
analysis at that particular time without
all of the stuff being used with the
technology today in computers and things
of that nature and certainly it gives
you tendencies of players but the bottom
line of it is is that smart players
react to what the defense does so if
you're going to play me and you're gonna
make me do something else I'm gonna be
prepared for that but I'm gonna react to
what you do that's why it's called
defense because you're on the defensive
if you're a great offensive player it
doesn't matter what the defense is doing
okay it makes no difference what the
defense is doing I'm gonna find a way to
beat you because you have to react to
what I'm doing and if you doesn't mean
the least little bit the wrong way all I
need to do is get my shoulder even with
enough to go by you I just have to get
you even with me so this thing that I
keep hearing about this lockdown
defender rich I was puke when I hear a
player saying this I mean did you guys
see this guy felt that he got locked
down some time buddy well then you
weren't a great player because great
offensive players who are scorers who
can shoot Drive shoot free throws and
all cannot be locked down period so what
do you think of what LeBrons been able
to do aged 33 in these playoffs where he
is now to win shy of making the NBA
Finals again with this Cavaliers team
Rick well I think he's playing great I
mean he's the best three to ever play
the game
very pretty three hitting come on your
best years Jerry Lester told me a long
time ago I got to be good friends with
Jerry west and we have so much respect
and admiration for Jerry and what he did
the greatest to until Michael came along
said Rick 30 28 to 32 gonna be your best
years he was right there was where my
bet my best year is right at the end
when I was there was LeBron shot that
far past and with today's technology in
the training and all of the eating and
everything else
sure that's probably longer than that
that you can go as long as you remain
healthy
so LeBron is really kind of like right
there in the time of the best years
because of the experience and all but he
has you know I don't know if people
really appreciate it just how difficult
some of the shots in Safety's with those
fadeaways that he keeps making he's
shooting better than he's ever shot in
his life
still can't shoot from the free-throw
line but he's making shots outside
incredible shots I mean seriously this
guy I saw him in high school
rich what I saw was and I felt like god
this has to be a great player just like
when I sat with Jerry West watching
Kevin Durant when he was in college
wish that there's an oh my god what a
pro this guy's gonna be when you were
watching him in Texas yeah huh what made
him look so great to you right then in
there wreck or something to tell you the
differentiation and I don't know what
the heck scouts are looking for I I
scouted a little bit you're early on
when I was that year I set out for the
Oaks and stuff and all and I saw a
number of players they sent me out to I
look for one thing the one thing I'm
looking for does the player have a
natural feel for the game that's the
different sheet that's a differentiation
between a good player and a great player
a great player has something that you
can never teach I can teach you how to
pass rich I can't teach you how to see I
can't teach you to know that if I throw
this ball right now in that little space
between those two defenders and throw a
bounce pass that the guy that's running
down the left side of the court it's
gonna be a perfect position to catch
that ball and take it to the basket you
can't teach that
you either have that feel or you don't
have that feel then you start looking
for it now is the athletic okay yeah
does he have a heart what kind of person
is he
those are the other things that you look
for but first that's what I'm looking
for I eliminate all the other people I
look for that guy then I'm gonna find
out more about him that's what you have
to do to use address X Barkley because
in pro sports three team sports the
major sports it's about the players who
do you draft who do you get in free
agency who do you trade for then you
hope you get a coach to this to screw
things up Rick Perry Hall of Famer here
on the Rich Eisen show Mike D'Antoni
says all the pressures on Golden State
tonight because if they lose then they
lose home court advantage and it's the
best of three with two in Houston what
do you say to that Rick
well it's nice thing to say but it also
is if they don't win they're going home
down three two one yeah I mean so it's
it's it's it's a double-edged sword that
you're playing with here you know
certainly I think Steve said the right
thing I saw a speech sound bite
yeah well he's right yeah we do we've
got to take advantage of our our home
court I mean that's the way it works you
want to win your games at home and the
Warriors did what they had to do because
they didn't have the home court
advantage they won one so now they just
have to take care of business at home so
obviously it's a crucial game for them
and but in the Rockets case I mean
they're in trouble because if the
Warriors win this one then they for sure
have to win their game at home and then
they got to find a way to win one still
back in Golden State so both teams are
in a situation this is the critical game
and it usually comes down to that
situation when you play that it's
usually a critical game in Game four
well then let's talk about this I'm
waiting to see if Harden can just
dominate in the same way that we've seen
Jordan do in the past LeBron Kobe I mean
I could go on and on you've seen the
greats all time brick you know you were
one how can a harden step up dominate
and get this right back to Game five the
MVP of the league do it tonight
how can he bring this one player can't
win not in basketball not one not one
player can't win he got 40 something in
the first game and they didn't win cp3
got 27 they didn't win you gotta find
out if the players can win then what
happens those guys that played so well
over there came played on the road they
do so well you don't win by yourself you
win because you do it collectively as a
team now you may have to play at a high
level to do it and here's what happened
with the other series is that LeBrons
teammate showed up finally showed up for
him he didn't have to score 40 points
for them to win that's why they are
doing two right now
and so now Boston has to go back and do
what and that juries it's the same thing
each team took care of business at home
so now Boston have to take care of
business at home that's why it could be
fun to see how it works out with a young
team that hasn't had this type of
exposing that exposure but experienced
yet to be in a situation like this so
I'm looking forward to seeing how they
play respond to this but I don't know
about you but I have I can't remember
watch playoff games at this level to see
two teams I'm talking about the Rockets
and the Celtics missed so many dunks in
in close shots to the basket it was like
somebody had the lid on top of the
sucker
it was unbelievable to me and it had a
major impact for Boston try to make some
comebacks and it certainly just killed
the Rockets because they blew a great
opportunity in this last game in Golden
State they may not even get an
opportunity in this next game because of
the fact that the work the workers came
out and we're horrible offensively in
the first quarter
yet the Rockets couldn't do anything
they were just as bad if not worse and
so they blew a wonderful opportunity to
try to get home court back and you're
not going to see the Warriors not show
up like they didn't get to back it used
to that I was embarrassed by that I know
they were as well because that's not the
rock that's not the team but the
experience they have to go out put a
performance like that uh but even in
that game rich first quarter they go 0
for 7 from threes right 0 for 7 for
three turned the ball over seven times
and they were only trailing by six
points so when it all comes down to it
Rick Barry it just seems like we're all
rearranging deck chairs once again
watching the Warriors do what they're
about to do if not tonight then against
whoever they faced LeBron or whomever in
the end the NBA Finals is this good for
the NBA
I know ratings are up revenues up
interest is up for sure but there is a
little bit of hand-wringing that the
only way that the Warriors could be
taken down is if they take themselves
down due to some sort of selfishness and
not wanting to share anymore and and
play together or LeBron goes and joins
the Rockets or has collide join him and
they get another player like Paul George
or something like that and create their
own super team well you know here's the
thing you have to play the game okay I I
lived it I know what it's like okay I
played on a team that wasn't even
supposed to be in the playoffs and we
won the biggest upset in history the NBA
Finals Bar None and we were able to
sweep a team that was supposed to sweep
us in the finals so I know what can
happen anything can happen in sports and
that's why we're playing the games now
on paper and the way things are going
yes everything is you said seems as
though that's predictable but it doesn't
mean it's going to happen
the Warriors still have to go out and do
what they do I said this before this you
started if the Rockets play is what
they can play and the Warriors play as
well as they can play on both ends of
the court the Rockets will not win the
Warriors will win but that doesn't
always happen and we've seen that happen
we've seen crazy Qaida games that have
taken place so far so it's good to be in
to see which team can show up and which
the hardest thing for any athlete to do
probably people in any space and
endeavour is to remain focused during
the time that you are out there
competing I as a coach can get you to
play hard because if you don't play hard
you know you're not playing but if
you're playing hard and you're not
playing focused you're a half a step
late and if you're a half a step late
and doing things defensively especially
at all you're toast
you're history and that's what we're
gonna find out which team has the mental
toughness to be able to remain focused
for the longest period of time to play
at the level they have to play for the
Rockets if all three of their guys and
think about this last game both times
that they've won rich they only had two
of their top three offensive threats
played really well and shoot the ball
well it was Katie and and clay in the
first game and it was Steph and Katie in
the second game because clay didn't have
a good game all three of those guys are
on shooting the ball well and they're
focused playing their defense the
Rockets will not beat them the Rockets
have to hope the two of those guys are
having bad games and if the two of them
have bad games then the Rockets must
play at their best to beat them Rick
always love our chats let's so let's
chat during the finals please anything
else going on in your yeah real quickly
have something that's helped me so much
he got me off a prescription drug and
I'll just put a goat ey be calm do you
IV calm /r Barry watch the video make
your own decision money back guarantee
you help your life get a little better
and the other one is a gift for anybody
that's listening if they want to get a
200 dollar free travel kiss get rewards
card go to our IC k2 for calm Ric k2 for
calm my gift to you enjoy it and I think
you'll you'll save some money and have a
nice trip you're the man rectal chat in
a week hopefully that's Rick berry whole
thing the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience